hey welcome to monitor hi I'm Peter
Reuben senior editor at Wired and this
week we have the return of Tony Stark no
not ghostface killah I'm talking of
course about the Marvel Cinematic
universe's most charismatic Lee acted
superhero Robert Downey jr. brings his
beloved idiosyncratic flawed Tony Stark
/ iron man 2 screened with iron man 3
this week it is officially the beginning
of popcorn blockbuster season what's
nice about this is the franchise manages
to bounce back from the nadir that was
the Mickey Rourke saddled iron man 2
what's also nice about this is the
series gets a shot in the arm from a new
director Jon Favreau has moved on to do
other things and Shane Black has come
into direct iron man 3 now why do you
know the name shane black only because
he wrote lethal weapon and long kiss
goodnight and wrote and directed kiss
kiss bang bang the sorely underrated
kiss kiss bang bang at any rate shane
black nose action this is big and loud
but it is not dumb so thank you Marvel
Universe for having the post Avengers
movies start off with not a total
letdown Iron Man 3 it's in theaters this
weekend let's talk about comics a few
years ago on Top Cow comics it was an
imprint called Joe's comics and it was
creations from the mind of J michael
Straczynski who you know from work and
comics and TV and film now Joe's comics
is back starting this week it is now on
image comics creator owned line Image
Comics and they have said that Joe's
comics is going to have a lot of new
ongoing monthly is like four of them may
be starting this year and they're going
to do six to twelve issue arcs now the
first one is called ten grand and it is
written by J michael Straczynski himself
and drawn by ben templesmith whose work
you probably know from 30 days of night
it's a it's a tale of a supernaturally
doomed hitman turned private
investigator who kind of strikes a deal
not with the devil with an angel it's
paranormal it's creepy it's got a little
bit
of a little bit of saga in it it's got a
lot of Hellblazer in it I really like
what they're doing so far it's a nice
start it's 10 grand starts this week on
image / Joe's comics so pick that up
let's talk about the little screen
television the idiot box now fans of
stand-up comedy and of comedy podcasts
obviously know the name Marc Maron he
has been a fixture in stand-up for
decades now and he had this resurgence
when he moved to the podcast space and
of course tower d WTF podcast with marc
maron now Marc Maron comes to IFC this
week Friday nights with marc maron's
kind of version of Louie and I mean that
it is a kind of semi-autobiographical
scripted show with a lot of recognizable
faces in it that follows the life of a
comic and podcast host and you know
twice-divorced a guy who's just dealing
with going into middle age and just
being a sour sob that's Marc Maron
persona we all know it we all listen to
it we all enjoy it on the podcast it is
in front of the camera now and there's a
ton of people I mean Judd Hirsch is in
it as his dad and there's a ton of
comedy stars to pop up Anthony Jeselnik
and Dave Foley and you know you name
them from comedy today or even comedy
yesterday and probably they're going to
pop up on on this series it is it's not
Louie I don't want you think that is
really but I mean that as a compliment
you know you knew there were going to be
knockoffs of that kind of show and this
is a knockoff in format only and it's
actually a perfect format from Marc
Maron he just has to be himself and
that's all he's really good at if you've
ever seen him try to act as anything
else I starts Friday nice it is on IFC
home of portlandia but that's it for a
monitor this week we will be back next
week with more pop culture goodness but
until then inspirational catchphrase
here